we are recording hi what's up its posted
three it's after the main event and we
got to play Resident Evil yeah we played
a resin equal to remake fans of this
show will probably be pretty amped that
that finally got announced I know so
good it played really well I think we're
gonna have hopefully they'll be like a
video of like some impressions that we
took at so I think the plan my initial
plan is to post it like as a bonus
episode after a normal Knievel episode
someday
that's a you did do impressions on it
like for GameSpot this is kind of
GameSpot kind of separate but we
actually shot like this camera normally
with us played through it it was really
cool the booth was set up like the
Raccoon City Police Department they did
such a good job too I mean there's some
other things that happen during the
recording that we won't spoil they had
post-its that had like I don't know
inside jokes and stuff they did you
tasty
yeah they a really good job really
recreating that environment anyway we'll
talk about that again another time yeah
I don't I put like when I'm in this
corner make him think about what he's
done Chris I am on Kasia
Leone so one thing we notice from the
remake the voice acting and like the
acting in general was really good they
really did and they changed some of the
dialogue which obviously I know we're we
all want to hear your party's been
canceled but I also feel that it's good
to like mix it up a bit yeah I mean
maybe heat Martin Branagh says it later
on he did not say at the normal time no
he did not
is this okay so I need this and what a
lot need an eagle plate now I've started
playing so if you want to tell me where
you think I should be going
that would be great but no you know no
pressure
it's been what two weeks do you want to
know a little bit about what I have yeah
I have your map I guess I have this mint
Clemente fancy e I think that's why I've
been coming it may be funky and the
Luger replica which I assume I can
replace for a net like a real Luger I
don't know yeah it's not a great time
for Mary I only have five bullets like I
don't have a lot here we got that we got
this stuff we mixed the chemical go to
your handgun what do you mean we just
inspect it hover over it
um you me to inspect my hand yeah okay
never mind
cuz you I know you got an upgrade on the
way okay no I don't think this I could
do that I don't think there's anything
on here but
oh no remember the hunters for God's up
yeah so you could be have gotten more
things than just this I remember what it
was remember there's a thing I said that
if you do it it will trigger the hunters
yeah you said I had to end because I was
gonna be in trouble with that doorknob
so I need more stuff hunters are more
susceptible to Bo right are they I can't
remember you're thinking of Bandersnatch
is either does man thinking about things
from res evil one that came into the
mansion alright well I can't bring
everything so what do you think I can
bring this bow gun and then I can bring
some bows or I can bring these bullies
but I shouldn't bring both right
I don't know Bo I don't know I don't
think you'll need a blue herb I don't
think hunters didn't poison you okay
what else can I get rid of do I need
this Luger you have extra shotgun shells
yeah I think I have shotgun shells bring
okay you got the inventory expansion the
last time so wait sorry do I not need
this bow gun I don't see how that's
gonna help against hunter okay and then
should I bring my bullets cuz I only
have five bullets yeah sure I don't
think you need the Luger what about the
Clement fancy II and then I'm just going
like hunting is that what's happening
you gotta go get that thing that was on
the ground that will trigger and then
you'll definitely have
shotgun and what are you at yellow I'm
at yellow and I have a red and green mix
and a green probably use your green
right now sorry he could probably use
your green right now sorry I'm exhausted
today the post e3 stuff is still a lot
of people at Twitter sick you know that
the e3 flu or whatever yeah let's do it
you ready yeah so am I going down the
drain I honestly don't member it's it's
close by so there's this drain and then
there's this way you know that way okay
I can't go this way so to the drain
alright let's [ __ ] these guys up you
might as well grab those and bring them
back up to that oh just do it now yeah
which I kill this guy
I remember now there's a shotgun raises
those levers
I don't think this is the way oh that
didn't shoot him
I'm just gonna pick these up and put
them in the thing cuz it's worth it yeah
and then I think you have to go across
the river at this point I thought it was
in the river yeah either order get up
the god dance ladder grits take the
stairs
but yeah you were writes down the letter
okay cool what was your favorite
announcement from e3 probably say Kiro
say Kyoto shadows that twice that or I
mean resonable to remake not just for
the sake of shows probably that's your
favorite zone like no oh yeah I mean if
this is remake is my favorite but like
numbered wise yeah 2 is but obviously it
remains to be seen how this January 25th
so yeah oh yeah we tweet we were
tweeting this during the show but
obviously the running joke was that we
got nowhere near close to finishing 136
before 7 came out but if we play this
presumably will play 0 next I think
right yeah 0 next which is still in this
style but it's the HD remake so it's not
tank controls it's like the ps4 remake
we played and then we'll play
Revelations 1 into the second of which
is very short and then we're trying to
finish those before January 25th so we
can play that people to remake like on
release day go down
if we can finish this by resonable to
release they I feel like we'll get a lot
of influx of he's he drowned
it's like here isn't it am i nuts I
thought the thing he was unidentified
monster came out of here I what was I
doing over here I thought it was in the
water it's definitely down here because
remember in order to go back upstairs
get to put the shotgun on those wall
levers we they wouldn't be here is it in
the other way it's across the walkway I
think oh so it's not here here no okay I
got confused I thought it was in this
water so that's where it's through there
that's where they turn on this and
there's also grenades there you go
you'll come back through here I don't
take them yet no you might see other
stuff all right so I'm going through
this door
and there might be Lucky's in here so
I'm just gonna change or well be okay I
know that like I'm pretty sure it's the
doorknob that triggers the hunters
because they are on a trigger if you
they don't come until you pick up I
can't remember
okay you got the serious sucks so scary
forgot what you've got in here you lift
it up those bio tanks yeah and there's
like obviously oh it's right there oh
it's all right you should get that
actually because I feel like good forget
that way back where is it it's on that
plan but you should be able to pick it
up right now yeah that'll be helpful I
was 50% nice where is that but I don't
have that it's in your inventory box
okay so I think it was that like I don't
know if you emptied it completely
against the worm where are we going
[Music]
[ __ ] stop
get it to calm yeah that thing down
there this will trigger hunters what
thing down there blowing the thing this
electricity no sorry it's kind of bright
oh that thing
Oh
this is the same kind of camera they use
in regular one it's very effective
watch him I have to kill him
yeah light a mob there's two of them
yeah
reloading is the trick oh [ __ ]
I died oh damn so it takes two what two
hits from them and you're dead [ __ ] I
did a lot damn it that sucks
hey what'd you get first I really
thought I liked damn those guys [ __ ]
me up just use the green one right off
of that but I like can't believe I died
so quickly I thought I had way more time
jeez they don't have knock back once
they're in the air apparently gosh I
would honestly not even bring ya bring
extra shotgun shells so we have enough
shotgun shells to kill these guys yeah I
don't think they're gonna take more than
four each all right do you think I need
more health I didn't even get to use it
cuz I died you're fine you're gonna have
to use that great here's what I think I
think I should not pick anything up go
kill them and then come back because I
could die again you don't name in like
knock at the red plants and go back
just like him on the way back yeah
that's alright for clip grenades and to
read plants
yeah you don't have a weapon to quit
just so you know right now I know
there's too many of them like why would
you give me two if you yep you in like
no room you manage the knock back
they're fine but
I might just leave them in there for now
I'm not hurting anybody
so many and they're so big you can't run
I don't think like how am I supposed to
kill these guys I am just pretty sure
that the game is unbeatable don't look
at me when the screen goes black Mary's
always just staring right at me in the
screen and the reflection it's a thing
that we have and it's been very
uncomfortable to not mention it until
now
Hunter x Hunter s two sons tone tone
tone tone tone tone tone tone tone tone
tone tone tone tone tone tone
just one one perspective yeah I know
they trick you into thinking there's not
[ __ ] him up oh that was a bad idea
wait that wasn't what I meant okay I'm
on cautious it depends on what they
attack you it I honestly think you
should just take it cuz then I can't get
hit again yeah I got it nice but yeah I
killed both of you is there anything
else in this room
oh yeah you can go bested what is there
something in here oh this is where I got
the stuff the sauce
okay the chemical sauce get all those
assault rifle into the red earth oh look
yeah there's this gimme gimme I think
that's it for here good to get though
let me out
doors are so confusing okay so I have
that it's always a struggle for me to
walk yeah yeah you'll like zero because
it's the HD remake controls here
electric boobs electric boobs
have you seen 27 dresses Katherine Heigl
seriously neither by no it sounds like
okay cool grenades really like wrong
just say yeah [ __ ] yeah it's the same
room you could put the shock in there
now cuz that's where I think we're going
anyway
wait don't go me to put the red herbs
away so you have one open space there's
two red herbs you're gonna put the
shotgun here when you come back anyway
so now you're freeing up a space so you
can just do to both the red herbs
but then I can't get through I see what
you say you were right
yes there's a new rom-com on Netflix and
now that I know that you're a big
rom-com fan I'm gonna recommend it for
you it's called set it up do you think I
haven't seen set it up I'm just kidding
I haven't seen okay it just came out set
up set it up for me so I don't typically
watch rom-coms but I was a sucker for
them like in the 90s and I think this
one's kind of reminiscent of like those
classic rom-com era oh it's a shame I
have to I can't get both what 90s
rom-coms are you thinking of referring
to I don't know it's think of like what
I used to watch oh don't let that see
you that caught those call hunters are
you know you should read right sorry
I run get it yeah get in there I hope
that calls off the alarm but those call
hunters I didn't know sweet what should
I do now find that with the sorrowful
okay
there's so much stuff that [ __ ] okay
anyway set it up is about to like
executive assistants who have like
really - like executives that they work
for The Devil Wears Prada and yeah
essentially and then they try to get
them to like be together so that they'll
be like they can bang so they're not
such dicks all the time get both laid
then though yes in the better mood
that's like the concept of it and it's
pretty funny cuz it's like setting like
a modern era where the characters Lucy
Liu if she wanted the executive she's
the main executive and I can't remember
anyway else nobody else have any value
stars Lucy Liu and other people
Lucy Liu anything else she's great in
this all right so should I get that
shotgun back or oh I need it so that I
can leave I'm dumb alright so I haven't
saved I don't think you need to okay cuz
if I die I'm gonna be magically so the
the scary thing about putting the
shotgun back is I think their cameras
upstairs that can call hunters and you
won't have the shotgun just don't get
caught by them
alright do I need this knob trying to
think if there's like maybe need arrows
for a banner snootch yeah you need that
or not I think
okay you probably put the shotgun shells
away because you're not gonna need those
blue red do I have any greens I could
combine a green and a red again sure
those have intrinsic value okay Oh for
[ __ ] sake Mary so dumb alright here we
go then okay cool
so that should be enough right yeah
let's find out if it's still there if
there's a hunter out here I'm in trouble
no just don't get seen by those cameras
like it Oh
oh it calls it permanently maybe you
should save here just things could get
dicey huh you have a lot of save ribbons
too don't you I think so I think I have
13 is that a lot feel like that's a lot
listen 15 this isn't a good place for me
I'm saying I would highly recommend
you're taking up space with your shotgun
children ow you're not gonna need more
than seven I didn't know you count it
was three shots for each hunter right
why is it yeah I think so yeah I mean
okay I think this goes without saying
and I'm not trying to be condescending
but let's make number one priority not
getting seen by those cameras I was
trying not to come off sarcastic because
I really didn't mean to be it's actually
one of my biggest issues yeah I know I'm
well not for me like I can usually
decipher I think we are past the point
where you offend me ever well I think
weapons is I have like this
mundane tone so when I'm saying
something sincerely like I like it it
doesn't sound like I'm being sincere
yeah yeah your dog Lord alright so for
instance that didn't hurt my eardrums at
all that sounded sincere I'm just going
to assume that it is it sucks I think
what sucks about this whole new system
is that I thought well now at this point
you might as well read loaded shotgun
then put you don't you don't get any
benefits from killing them no it's it's
not a you know I mean like I got a
modern gamer I just basically lost
shotgun shells which are incredibly
valuable is what just happened yeah that
was my exchange
yeah those cameras are not [ __ ]
around but there's two of them I could
escape one camera but two discs yeah
let's talk about did you sit you saved
right yeah damn I wish you'd say before
you guys seen but I won't camera I would
honestly recommend wiping it's coming
toward you right now oh it's only going
I don't know how to dodge still coming
how do you dodge it just don't yeah they
go
just wipe
let's do redo that part
let's crush my coffee how does this you
had it's honestly just a matter of
timing
or just I pass him he doesn't see you
but don't had to come back here yeah I
think the latter you gotta go down suck
it's very upsetting I felt like I was
joking the system but I didn't juking
the system it's a sick band name juking
the system Mary alright alright so I'll
put these back
kill that Bandersnatch cuz or whatever
cuz in this one I haven't done it yet in
this save I'm glad I saved and then
that's it right we're just gonna go with
this much stuff or should I put these
away wait was this is this say when
there's already a hunter in the hallway
yes I have to kill it I don't really
[Music]
understand hello Joe I don't understand
how Joshua's cameras I don't play it as
long as that beam doesn't touch you fine
like you dodged the first one just
literally don't let it touch it yet go
go go before they turn back out nice I
cuz they go really fast
[Music]
there are more upstairs though it also
it redder if you didn't get I don't know
if he want that wait are you saying I
need the shotgun shells cuz I thought
you said I didn't need the shot you
don't need the fire you have the shotgun
tells me no yeah you don't yeah did you
get those grenades right I've got the
grenades this week so now you can use
the doorknob I forget where but we'll
figure it out uh the elevator I think
I think those things are mean like the
idea that there's just like these
constant yeah skinnies where should I go
second floor I went to first nice why is
the cameras UI is up it looks like we're
fine
I think oh my god yeah those noises are
awful
No scanty noises I know so I was trying
to mimic hmm
noise
[Music]
okay
oh god okay there's one on my second
floor
yes what I just forgot for you gone back
in yet
should I kill that thing yeah where does
the knob go the age-old question like is
it down here
can I go down here no oh hey that's the
first floor no no I don't think you're
supposed to it's too late oh yeah you're
down where Steve was but I don't
remember what's down here
it's that diagram of you should go back
up I think what's this a locked door
maybe that's the doorknob door what the
top door go back up
all right I'm gonna kill this zombie ate
this area I'm I do not have a lot of
bullets and I and I didn't bring my
knife cuz I'm dumb so I have like
literally nothing I can take this guy I
feel very strongly about it
I [ __ ] up I got it I'll do a second
juking all right oh you didn't think you
did it I didn't laughs at work I think
yes
oh this is the [ __ ] in the water yeah no
I think you just go across that doors
along the doorknob through here horse
door no come on
Jesus Christ [ __ ] oh my god tell me what
to do think you're in the right spot
right no no no don't go through there
here in the right room already one of
these at the doorknob door there you go
freed up a spot um I hope it's like a
save room I'm in this room I guess
that's that diagram thing downstairs for
the diorama dijah vamos the di Rama huh
ooh gimme gimme gimme gimme my neither
those doing so hot what's my health
all right I can't get down I gotta go
back the way I came all right so now
we're going to the diorama correct to
the other balcony to go down the
elevator okay do you think there's
anything else in here that I missed
unless there's a raging fire down there
I just walk into fire yeah it's fired
originally by the the room where you
found the crossbow
I believe God like hopefully that
cameras like off I hate but I don't
think it to come back through here so if
there is a hunter I just dodge it once
you fire well don't don't let the
cameras to begin oh god where is it I
don't think it bothered you until you
get out into the hallway see it's like
in that whole area just so scary where
is it oh it's it's past those things are
actually very scary tis the threat
of the camera that's more scarier than
the camera itself no reason to go down
here shy look this is where the dogs
were I don't know what's going on down
here now I don't know what the [ __ ] goes
on down here this thing exploded and
then that's where the thing fell
oh that emblem that would be yeah what
we want to pick up just go back the
Steve garage and then into the diorama
room I don't remember where the diorama
is forgotten through yeah keep coming
this way this door yeah that one almost
got me okay yeah elevator it's in the
double door like down here the diorama
the diorama room it's where you got with
that red skull painting yes I don't know
what its gonna do if it's gonna [ __ ]
with the tank in real life or what would
that be cool you could just drive a tank
throughout the rest of the game maybe I
would be nice just can't fit down
hallways don't have a scanner wait
I don't remember this at all
Oh No so sorry I went the wrong way
this isn't right yeah this where you
fought the worm go back up it's a door
off the garage I didn't remember like
this entire animation I was like I'm
dead
that goes outside I believe
are you sure it's from oh is that always
the way it was no do you want look at
the MIT I'm trying to see what maybe
it's on a different room floor
no it's on the first floor so maybe it's
at this sorry it's this stuff so you'd
have to go up and then down these stairs
and through here because that doors
locked from the fire okay I'll give it a
whirl all right so I'm going back up
here here yes I think so yeah I've used
this lift several times
unnecessarily today
so learning process
why they call it was D controls what's
that oh right that guy where am I going
into the elevator I said that the other
day in the office and someone actually
answered me they fell for my troll I
asked what was yeah I asked him what I
call Massey controls you do that all the
time you like say something dumb on
purpose and then when someone answers
you just smile yeah all right there's
nothing over here there was no reason
for me to get hurt
how hurt a my gosh okay
not great
all right so what have we learned we're
going the elevator however you get to
the diorama I don't know where the
diorama is it's on the first floor which
open the map so we can go through here
again and go downstairs but I don't
think I can go around that whole like
the thing that got broken mm-hmm like in
here right here's the hole I think you
were saying let me just clarify with the
map you were like go down these stairs
and go tear and I don't think I can you
might have to go back into the room with
the camera I say I don't mind doing that
I just want to only do it once so it's
like if I meant it if I'm gonna if I
can't go this way this is [ __ ] broken
great I mean you get to diorama room
let's find a way to do it where I don't
have to go through 8 cameras and then be
like [ __ ] this isn't the right way like
this is not the time for us to be
investigating kind of have to though
yeah you'll know where we're going
allocations suspending in 15 minutes
because license cannot be verified it
did the internet shut off and it doesn't
I don't know I have 15 minutes
well that's actually like that would be
the episode anyway so let's just play
sure a bit hopefully it strip the
internet should bring up no I don't want
people to see my yeah wait hon bring up
my you bring up my playstation menu
[ __ ] you maybe you like the Internet
shut off for a second I think we'll be
fine
sure alright so I'm in an area that has
god damn sure didn't even think about
like lasers yeah
sorry I'll go back to the well you want
me to do about the lasers also are you
on the map I'm on the first floor join
me to go through here or no sir we're
sorry
hallway diorama is it that's a safe room
right at the very bottom are you on the
first floor I'm on the first floor
I just dodged this camera and going to
the next room [ __ ] you there what to the
right yeah try that what's down there am
I going in that door oh it's so this
one's only going up and down yeah go
past that
I don't understand am I just going
through the door yeah
once you get past it nice let's hope
this is the way you're supposed to go I
just said that to boost your confidence
I actually don't know thank God oh nice
yes this is it that's good Chum I
totally knew there's a hole to put
something in why have I not made a joke
about that yeah oh my god I think you do
every time really lasers lasers thought
I got a key I got a secret passage note
there's always the underground passage
which leads to the mansion where Alexia
and I live has been badly damaged
although I can never allow the unwashed
to see Alexia I cannot go on using the
underground waterway that those local
people made either underground well
there's a water like it the water
oh yes I think I'll have those prisoners
build a bridge it must be a gorgeous
bridge that benefits the perfection that
that beef it's the perfect faction that
is Alexia thank you so much slaves of
course I must we don't use the S word
its prisoners that we don't pay to do
things yeah you're having Stockholm
Syndrome with a lifesaver
of course I must kill everyone who's
involved in the construction of the
bridge after it is done so that no one
will know about the existence of our Mon
Seon but that is okay as I have no
problem executing such matters once the
bridge is completed also the mansion the
entrance of the waterway is locked by
the do Rama ensuring the secrecy of our
mansion as long as no one finds his memo
Lee lead three armies here and the path
will open okay no I do not what do I do
now so I got a key I got a key I got a
turn table key I only got one turntable
the sun-god one turntable and a Mack
what am i doing
this is in the scanner room how they
turned it off that'd be funny if it
turned on right when you were under it
that would be [ __ ]
all right okay that's where the barrel
is so you were right just de barrel in
the way I guess head back toward the
shotgun waterway because that's what the
note seemed to be pointing toward is
that on to know basically what it's in
the basement
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] it was a long time ago when we were
first powering those Spencer mansion
elevator that's like more than a year
ago I know is it crazy like how far
we've come play a lot what's that noise
I think you could take a shotgun and
that red herb yeah but what am I doing
with it
like I got this key but I gotta use it
why would have back to the saver of Mary
Ashe anyway is it time to save oh good
you have enough just in case of the art
it's just application cows get suspended
I want to head back that way anyway no
saving three times seems excessive but
like if they're gonna if it's gonna
close [ __ ] spit some [ __ ] at me did
you see that yeah hey might look at that
red herb and everytime I save I have to
go through that [ __ ] scan ease
double scans dub scan scans no thanks
like I don't like this at all no yep
well doesn't matter I think there's
another way this way let's do that too
before we call it let me just put away
some of these [ __ ] I have a lot of stuff
do I want all these things these are a
few of my shotgun nice oh my god what's
at the other end of how I passed the
manhole oh the lift is stopped on the
upper floor so wait what can you press
the button there
so I got this key maybe have to go
across the to the other side of those
all those pods are yeah
[Music]
come on god I hate you
I'm missing so many things I need like a
emblem and I need like a thing oh what
the [ __ ] am i doing over here yeah I
don't know where to go anymore oh [ __ ]
wait hold on this is key related no
you're going the right way but go back
sorry what did I do
no you didn't do anything wrong get
Clement Sigma oh I need the GU it's not
that bad I can do that sincerely hope
that that internet kickback in our know
what that was we have yeah spare no
expense here at GameSpot
this guy's so this learn how to use
stairs all right so I'm gonna get some
Clement that's a street here in San
Francisco
yeah Clement Street lot of dope spots on
it
they should use one of these symbols
anything else well I'm here I don't I'm
sure we'll shotgun shells maybe really
yeah we're [ __ ] even your crossbow if
you're gonna start seeing Bandersnatch
what do you think I'm gonna see more
banner snatches not hunters might see
hundreds but I think I know you're
coming back up which like crossbows are
good for that right I don't remember
I suppose explosive powder I just want
to kill stuff and no I I don't think you
need to curb mixtures I'm sorry for my
yawning yes it's the time they really
get rid of one of those [ __ ] are my
shotgun shells
wait no I haven't saved in a while yeah
no cross yeah bring the crossbow want
the crews bow - so you're getting rid of
the key soon hopefully if we're going
the right way and you're getting rid of
the mixture hopefully the right way and
bring some arrows I guess actually no
okay here's here's the deal
reload your shotgun don't bring the
extra shells that'll only be like yeah
get rid of those extras no you can't get
I don't think you can make explosives if
they're already loaded into the crossbow
you guys speak up
I could be wrong I have another 30 here
so I can do it the deed is done and it's
done dirt cheap and it's done diddly
deee deee deee then they're done dirt
cheap hey yeah I'm on caution you know
that right sitting on your biscuit never
having to risk it
alright filling a pearl on you
I never let anyone in her along do you
know in Australia they there's a term
well you would notice
they say that someone unders thunders
yeah I've heard in that song I can tell
you lots of weird Australia facts from
my time there what does Vegemite is it
gross long time nose oh my god that
music what are you doing here I came for
Alexia who an organization hired me to
come here
wait you attack the island and my sister
[Music]
justice glasses got'em eyes
[Music]
slapping use a little secret Chris
slapping I figured I think your sister
is now in the Antarctic with Alexia it's
oh that's new ch yeah what am i doing
kill it
um arrows or should I run arrows I guess
arrows what yeah but you got to move
because those things can hit you from a
distance
I know and I'm on caution maybe your
shotgun
well I can't hit it hey he's right there
you could shotgun oh crap
okay wait okay yeah you should move
though
nice [ __ ] Martin you go you don't
give up
yeah yeah yay good thing about the kree
smile in your face suck arrows dick get
dick alright now I keep going down here
yeah in here yeah so I think the key is
to finish the mixture if memory serves
oh [ __ ] this area what is very-- got the
door no uh it's safe you can't go
through there yet right this is which is
broke oh yeah go into the mixer okay I
hope but that's where that's what a
turntable be I think they mentioned that
earlier is like a chemical mixture thing
those are shotgun shells right there oh
my god are they yeah how we miss this
bless you
was I I'm like missing something obvious
there's like a key somewhere
where does the key are you sure it's in
this room no okay oh this is where you
made the first Mickey yes so is that
less likely now I mean what did it where
did the Wesker go out a door that you
can use now or something
hopefully there's a broom up here [ __ ] I
hope so I'm like a little nervous here
we've accomplished a lot I'm not in
great health
wait what is that you see it there's a
little it's a little nugget of info up
there do you see it yeah am I crazy
what is that looks like a tape how do I
get it
can you get around the crate and push it
this way what create that wouldn't one
yeah climb over it and push it back this
way that's smart
cool
very cool
No do the thing thank you jump up jump
up thank you
are you [ __ ] kidding me toward the
camera I thought that was like as far as
I could do it take controls I might have
messed up that sucks
well I pushed it this way first before
pushing it this way sometimes I just
wonder if it's just I mean I was off by
like a centimeter look at it when I want
to just go to the edge so it's Bo
gunpowder so it's not like crazy yeah
but can you get on down off this side
like keep quiet no climb down on this
side Oh
no that's stupid that is stupid it's
right there I just don't understand what
I did wrong it's like definitely not
letting me push it anymore sorry that's
really annoying it's like right there
where am I what am i doing all right
where am I going down here or over here
are I don't know try that smaller door
oh my god should I take these yeah you
can put all those on the crossbow if you
want do you need space yeah go through
the small door come on
orange could you heal if you want I
think it's worth it I take your hand
that out save that for the bender Smith
if there are any more I'm sure there
will be
got him I feel like shotgun shells in
the ground too
he's like not coming after me that's
weird also I just realized we are on the
second floor with the shotgun so we
found a way to bypass the whole stair
key thing oh yeah in the second floor
butter he stuck one idiot he's that he's
dead do you want any butter I cannot
open it can't open butter just wait
check the table yard right yeah there's
some soda you mean over here there's a
bag from Tiffany's over here
okay an explosion over here let me just
check these lakis should probably take
those this looks dangerous
no camera no camera where am I
there's also that large area - oh you're
down here now on the other side of that
hole he's he's definitely alive
you disgust me okay he's dead should I
go through the other way or should I
keep going this way this might be a dead
end doctor here nope
so continue down this path or go down
that large area I think this is the way
you're supposed to go but you could try
the large area just to see what's in
there if you can save it now that might
be a good spot since we know what we're
doing I would really like to save I'm
like very nervous that I'm gonna die I
have anxiety about death currently Oh
God if I could save that would be
fantastic I also have to pee I also have
to pee that's like we have lots of
gauges about whether or not it's time
one of them is peeing one of them is
that we need to save one of them cuz
he's in the way can I turn around
[Music]
that's a Galago that way yes it was like
two of them in there so that was the
quarry over the tank or sorry that where
the worm used to be right man I hope I'm
not like putting myself in boss
territory here guys
let's try this let's try the old sewer
save no I don't think this will media
don't do this yet this will trigger
stuff I know okay you're gonna pull out
your shotgun out you're gonna have to
kill this you know they're the only the
closest save room is past them I don't
have any health I know but you've got
the shotgun which is fine you took them
out without any help last night no I
died last time no last time you died
twice ago and then you figured out so
the save room has passed them that's
your best bet this is what the show is
about [ __ ] up hunters no I don't want
to I want to safely live it's here right
I have no desire for them Lord God tell
me where the safe room is you're fine
you're fine you already ami at them
you're good I'm on caution dude yeah but
you're there like both lined up you just
need to make sure you shoot them before
they jump both of them well done ah now
you can leisurely search for the next
save room I think it's I honestly don't
remember but no that was a large threat
out of the way you should feel good
about yourself maybe that way there's
stuff on those crates
Boggan arrows maybe leave those for now
Tatum they'll combine leader yeah so the
tank is through there I don't know if
does that go to a safe room what's
what's over that's where it came from
right no this right here yeah try that
double door okay you haven't been in
there yet that was locked the whole time
you're playing as Claire oh right it
does Oh Lord it's an elevator though I
know but you know that I oh my god can
you move
no this is [ __ ] funny if Wesker's
here knew that's like the final fight no
but it's like why did I go down here
oh the safe room isn't it yeah sweet
bless you good sweet so now we know we
got a lot to do next and a good ending
Oh Phil do hunters he got a yellow baby
heart all right I never used this gu hai
that's the what you're you were doing
the other way yes
so I can go pee okay so yeah that's
scary that's good no ice we back and
soon we'll be doing a Resident Evil 2
yeah I don't think it's going to be
right after this episode's gonna be next
weekend where isn't evil to isn't out
yet
I'm with the new one oh yeah sorry got
some work to do yes we all right thanks
everybody for joining us always have a
good rest of Saturday and what's going
on this weekend Father's Day was last
weekend this weekend I traveled to Ohio
I'm gonna go see my family which means
I'm not here next week I should've told
you that you can't record next week I
can't
maybe we can later this week you can or
I can maybe just use resonable to as a
stand-in I'll figure it out okay either
way we'll be in your face holes somehow
next week yeah if you have time we talk
about later but if you have time I can
support tomorrow's I finished it
maybe yes okay well anyways bye everyone
bindery weekend what's left remember
when I hot juked that is
the system my new band